μέσα καινωνικής ικτύωση όπως τοαες που ερκαι λιπά όπου καλούνται οιτα θέομαυτί που διαφέρονται πασή
περιπτώσει να επενδίσου να ακολουθήσουν μια σελίδα ι σελίδες αυτές είναι αληθοφανείς στην αρχήνι οληθεφανίς
και προκαλούν να επενδήσεις ες το και τα έχουν μικρό χρηματικό ποσο πεντακόια ευρώπαρα τον
ποσκάλι βάζουν τα πεντακόσα ευρώ και δείχνουν ότι μετά απόδέκα μέρες τα πενταγόσιαυρό χοχίνι γίνει
χίλια διαγόσια σε σύντομο χρονικό διυτημα με μεγάλα κέρεται αυτό υπόσχονται και φόσ το δείχνου
ότι υπάρχουν και πεντακσια που μαλλικέ υμερκές φορές τους λένε δείξετε μου και το λογαριδόμα
αυτα ενμβάσω τα λεφτά είναι η ζημια γιααυτος σκ λογαργιασμόσου παίρνουν αντια σοβάλο και τας
και μπορές του πιβάσου και το πωόο καμερκιές φορές και εσύ οσιά ενθουσιάζεσε και αρχή
της και πλέπεις υπάρχει κέρδος και σου λένε ύστερα βάλε πια πολλά μηου τις πεντ
ευρ δεν ασχολομε μεδέτκα μικρόπασά όπλώς ένα ανδείκμα τώρα εγώ που ουδείχνο οι αν θέλει
να επενδήσουμε γιατίείμαυτες σοβαρή σε ι αγωγικά και πάλι εταιρία είμαστε σεβαρατερία πρέπε αβάλεις ένα
τεπ τό πόσομα και αρχίζουμε και βάζουμε έκαχ πια καπεντε χιαδες ίκωσι δες δείχνουν με
αναλυτικές μάλιστα καταστάσεις ότηταχύα πενταπόσι αυρώ τα δέκα λα αυρώ έχουν αξημένα κέρδι έχουν πολύ
καλές από αποδώσεις και είναι εκεί που σε καλούν να αρχίζει να βάσε τις πιο
σημαντικά ποσά οιατί πλαφόρμα υτή τεπροκαι νακλήσει διαφορες τις διολογίες και είναι εκεί που τα
χάνισαέχουμε περιπτώσεις τριά θριών εκατομιρίων που έχουν χαφεί τριώ εκατομυρίον που έχου χαφεί και τις
πλεγόμες μέρες απόσαμε ότι πήραν και διαμέρισμα διαμέρισμα έχουν μια ληπεριουσημεταγόσες χύλιάδες που έχουν εμβάσει
και το φέμα με το κρυπτονομίσμε θα είναι ότι ττα χρήματα γιααξία τωνρ